[Music]
the slides for my talk are available on
my
website f herald.com so go there you can
you can get the slides and
inside the slides you'll see the links
to the demonstration reports that i'll
be
showing you parts of in this talk also
if you want to follow somebody on
twitter who likes to criticize poorly
done statistics or poorly done machine
learning
follow f2 twitter
be glad to have you there discuss those
issues and more
so just a brief mention of interactive
graphics and what sort of levels of
interactivity
most of you know this really well but
there's full interactivity
using tools such as r shiny where you
can change your
mind about what variables you're
analyzing and
how you're analyzing them such as how
much smoothing to do in a non-parametric
smoother but what i'm going to be
talking about
today is partial interactivity so what
sort of things can you do with
partial interactivity you can zoom and
pan
rescale axes provide extra information
using pop-ups such as hover text when
you hover the mouse over
an area and then very importantly is you
can select which
traces of data that you want to show
which elements of a graph
do you want to show and then instead of
having legends and explanations
i think it's better to have information
available on demand so instead of
devoting
space to things to explain what are the
elements of a box plot when you hover
over that part of a box plot just have
the definition of
which quantile you're showing pop up for
you
so i'm using the plotly package which
i'm a huge fan of
which is using the famous d3 javascript
graphics library this in my mind is the
best
partially interactive scientific
graphics system
and it has its own language for the
graphs it's something you have to learn
it's much different from gg platoon's
language
but it gives you a lot of flexibility
you can also
just convert any ggplot2 graphic to
plotly automatically if you like the way
ggplot2 laid out things but if you want
to add things sort of trace by trace
you might want to do what i did was go
most straightly to
plotly so there's some new
plotly graphics functions i've been
adding to my existing packages over the
last couple of years
and i've been adding a lot of html
methods as i get more away from latex
and pdf
into html i've added a whole lot of
functions for creating
customized html output that you can
include
right in your reports and there's
special htl method
html methods for the describe function
and the summary m function
summary m is like for creating table one
in a clinical trial report um
his box p is for making spike histograms
with extra information added to them
surf plot p is for making interactive
survival plots
and then there's an advanced html table
makers using the
html table package in our
so let's get to clinical trial reports
so the applications i'm talking about
are where you're doing say a randomized
clinical trial to study a treatment
versus some control
or you might be doing a drug study or
something in the pharmaceutical industry
and there's two types of clinical trial
reports there's sort of final clinical
trial reports and there's interim
reports
as often used in monitoring the conduct
of a clinical trial
that you might give to a data monitoring
committee also called a data and safety
monitoring board
and so uh the task that i started with
was developing high level abstractions
uh for the job of creating reports most
statisticians when they create a big
report
they sort of start over they may have
some code they used from previous trials
but they do a lot of new coding and it's
quite repetitive
so if you can make high level
abstractions i think you can
foster better statistical analysis and
better reporting practices and make
everything
reproducible and really minimize
programming
reviewers of reports about
human subjects research
get get really tired of reading through
tables and they usually fall asleep
they don't pay attention to things and
tables are not that good for showing
patterns anyway
and so we really want to get rid of that
now there's many standard components
to clinical to our reports these are
some of them uh a summary of how you
were able to accrue subjects into the
into the study uh how did the patient
flow occur
and what sort of exclusions did you find
uh
between the accrual or the screening of
subjects
before you randomize them to a to
experimental treatment
describing baseline variables
longitudinal analysis
adverse event analysis lab safety
parameters
event timing and incidents and
sequential monitoring
of event probabilities
so the philosophy is that tables
really do not lead to pattern
recognition and graphics are better
if you have more than two numbers i
think a graph is better than a table
in other words graph is almost always
better and graphs should use features
that humans are really good at
perceiving
such as position along a common scale
and then we need signposts on the
graphics so when i'm reading a long
report i lose track of where i am in
terms of
say which subjects are currently being
displayed or analyzed and i'll show you
what that means
tables are secondary they can be in an
appendix or hyperlinked
or what's better i think is to have
pieces of tables as hover text
from a plot and then this was
probably a little more controversial
most
studies where you're doing an a b
comparison the way an a b
comparison is really created is that
confidence intervals for a
are not relevant to the design and
confidence intervals for b
are not relevant to design they're
actually inconsistent with a parallel
group design
but the design is made to give
confidence intervals for differences
between a and b and that's what we want
to emphasize
we want to show the entire distribution
when possible
favor quantiles over means and standard
deviations
and then i personally don't like
percentages and i do everything i can to
get rid of percentages
that's a personal opinion so i have an
older package that use the latex and pdf
model and this is a very very stable
package it's been around for
many years used in production in in some
really huge multinational
clinical trials and then the newer
package which is not on cran yet which
is h report
for html report so in these packages
there's lots of utility functions high
level report components
unified handling of figure generation
and captions so
when you write a long report you spend a
lot of time writing figure captions
so the figure captions are all
automatically generated by these
packages and then there's some new
graphical elements
so the high level functions are accrual
report
exclusion report descriptive statistics
event report and serve report for time
to event
analysis now when you're writing a
package and you want to implement things
at a high level
you really have to survey best practices
and it's your opportunity to implement
best
practices and also to create best
practices if people like the package
and so instead of doing one-off reports
if you start saying what should be in a
patient screening report or accrual
report
and really nailing that and then making
it so that
people can join the project on github
and they can extend the report with new
options
or change the format it's much better
than just
coding from scratch for each report
uh number at risk report and in the
future there will be a sequential
monitoring boundary
sort of report and the the format of all
these functions the way you call them is
using the formula language you have your
analysis variables
on the left hand side of the model
separated by plus
and then you have your stratification
variables and optional id variable if
you're analyzing something where there's
multiple records per
subject so our markdown creates html
documents and these allow
semi-interactive graphics so if you're
using plotly
these these this uses html widgets and
those are included in your html without
you doing anything special whatsoever
and they'll display beautifully on
virtually any browser and they'll
automatically resize for viewing on a
tablet and it's very effective to view
these reports on a tablet
and then r functions write html they
write regular tabular output
hyperlinks navigation bars and almost no
tables
and then hovering over a part of a
graphic will display the relevant
portion
of the table so i don't i don't display
whole tables anymore
but just portions of tables on demand
so now we get into the two examples
and then if you if you download this
slide you can click on these links to
see
see them in in much more detail
first thing you notice is we have a new
table of contents function
in the hmis package that it doesn't
waste so much space on the left with
your floating table of contents and it
allows you to specify the level
uh so if you click on three you'll get a
three level outline and if you click on
two you just get a two level
and one is a one level but the most
important thing is to be able to get rid
of
the outline altogether
and so the other thing that we have in
the
in this you see that little l that's a
little figure
icon for a graph so that means this is a
figure
and this is a short figure caption and
clicking there will go to that figure
this has about a bunch of philosophy
stuff and then uh
notes about figure captions and these
are the signposts
that are used uh in each graph and so
uh to keep me aware of where i am in a
report
i have these signposts below each graph
and so what that means is you have a
little bar
here where the red is telling you uh how
many of the enrolled subjects are
included in the current
analysis being displayed so if you saw a
bar like that that's full height that
would mean you're analyzing all the
enrolled subjects
this would mean you're analyzing three
quarters of the enrolled subjects but
all of the randomized subjects
this would show that you're analyzing
one-fourth of the enrolled subjects
and only one-half of the randomized
subject so the green is the proportion
of randomized subjects you're currently
analyzing and then if it's stratified
for treatment you'll get two more
and the last two bars will tell you what
proportion of those randomized to one
treatment
are currently being considered in the
analysis what proportion randomized to
another
treatment b are being considered
and then this is the first output and
you can click on code to see the code
for any of these
uh this is the accrual report so this
this actually took one of the longest
uh times to write because when you have
a multi-site clinical trial that may
also be a multinational clinical trial
you have countries region sites so it's
a very hierarchical organization
and to really summarize a multi-site
multinational trial
the way that you need to it took a
little bit of thought but this is a
trial snapshot
so you get your overall summaries about
the
the trial content and how many people
are passing the screening stage
then you get your accrual and this is
where plotley comes in because you
you can just hover and see your target
numbers of patience you should have had
accrued by that time versus uh
and i think i just expanded something
versus the actual number that you've
accrued by that time
you see that's may 1994.
uh there is the little signpost over
here
which you could barely see probably from
where you are and there's a there's some
fine details showing you the number of
non-missing observations
analyzed in the groups being analyzed
you can just zoom in on that to see
detailed denominators this is just a dot
chart showing the number of
sites how many subjects were randomized
at how many
sites so looking at the the
randomization frequency
oversights and then we have uh
another graph like that then we start to
get into baseline variables
and this is where we start using the
features of plotly uh more effectively
so this is just showing the proportion
of females in treatment a and in
treatment b and you see on the right the
legend shows you
uh the color code for treatment a and b
which is used throughout the report
and then if you hover over that you'll
see that this is .222
of the subjects were female in treatment
a
and this was for all regions and you can
see the numerator 18
and the denominator is 81. so one thing
i learned
early on in this is you always give
numerators denominators because
somebody's going to ask you
you don't want to leave it to guesswork
the other element of this graph and of
course you can
you can turn things off by clicking here
so if i didn't want to show the
stratified data by region i can just
click on the right
and that will turn those traces off
that's just a nice feature of
plotly which you'll see more in a minute
but the other design
consideration here is when you're
showing the proportion randomized to a
in proportion randomized to b whose
smoke which is these two dust down here
you also see it stratified by
region so and you can see that this is
north the north region here
so i think of the stratification by
region as
something that's subservient to the main
stratification
so the main stratification is treatment
a versus b
and if i want to further stratify by
region those dots are below the main
dots
and they're smaller so to denote that
those are subservient or minor
stratification
i'm using a smaller size and if you
click on the legend you can turn those
off
now this is the way i've settled as my
favorite way to display
continuous data is really you need to
show the data
and box plots don't really have a good
ink to information ratio
they just don't show enough a box plot
will not show by modality
it'll completely hide it but a histogram
will show by modality
if you have digit preference in your
data more
more numbers entering in five or zero
you'll see digit preference very clearly
and so i found the secret formula for
how many bins there should be a
histogram it's either 100 or 200
independent of the sample size but if
you're if you have fewer than 100
distinct values in your data you would
use that fewer number as the number of
bins
but you essentially have one bin per
possible value up to about 200 bins
and that way you have all the resolution
you need and it scales to huge data sets
but in addition to showing the histogram
which has a lot of information
you can show the elements of the box
plot plus more
so you can see that below each histogram
you see the
mean is with a dot the median is with a
big
vertical bar and then you see the
quartiles in the 0.05
and 0.95 quantiles so you see all the
box plot information plus more
but the histograms are more informative
and then if you wanted to turn off
the box plot stuff you just click here
and that's that's no longer there so you
can easily turn that off
so that's how i display uh continuous
data that's stratified by treatment you
see this for a bunch of variables
and you'll see on all these displays uh
like here in the fine print
you'll see denominators for each uh
variable being displayed there's a
number of non-missing values
then there's various displays for
longitudinal data this is for longitude
no binary data like adverse events
i display that lots of different ways
and then for just showing overall
incidents of adverse events
i just use a dot chart where each dot
you're showing the proportion
that have that event and if you hover
over you'll see this is uh
diarrhea treatment be 20 out of 169
subjects had that event but then you
have a confidence band for the
difference and if you
if you position that at the midpoint of
the two and it's the half of the width
of the confidence interval
that has the property that it touches
those two dots if and only if there's no
significant difference at that
alpha level that you're using for the
confidence interval
and then if you hover over
the bars
you will see um
you know i can't get that that to pop up
right now you're supposed to see the
actual confidence intervals for the
difference
and you can turn those confidence
intervals off if you want by clicking in
the right
lots of ways to display longitudinal
data
and then i want to show you just um just
one
item from the other report
this is the um exclusion report
and so it analyzes what is causing
patients to be excluded and it
it doesn't ask you what order to analyze
those and it finds
the major exclusion which would be here
no significant coronary artery disease
that excluded 11 subjects from the trial
and then what excluded the next largest
number of subjects
was pneumonia within six weeks
and then for each exclusion it reports
the incremental exclusion so how many
new subjects are excluded
because of pneumonia after you've
already excluded
those without cad and it shows the
marginal exclusion so how many people
will be excluded because of pneumonia
whether or not they were excluded for
anything else
and then in terms of survival
report this is the kind of output you
get what i really like about it besides
having a confidence interval for the
difference
of two kaplan-meier curves or this is
one minus this so this is cumulative
incidence curves
is it recognizes that the number at risk
is really a continuous variable so i
don't want to just show the number at
risk at yearly intervals
i want to show that as a continuous
function of the follow-up time
so as you hover over these different
areas you will
you'll see that you'll see the number of
at risk at exactly that time point
it's just another way where i think you
can use plotly
very effectively so uh
if you get the repo the slides and go
into those clicks you'll see those
and more information can be attained at
these
these three sites so thank you very much
for listening
we have a few questions we have a few
minutes
so one of the more popular questions is
there a function to make
consort diagrams or can you do alluvial
plots for patient flows
that was asked might have been the
person asking it now asked that on
twitter the other day and somebody
responded to use one of the
general figure drawing uh packages in
our like
i think i know it's tick z or when they
use this graph is but i don't think
anybody's packaged those sort of things
into a ready to use function i think it
would be nice
maybe we'll do one more question how can
a staff statistician working in clinical
trials do you think
convince pis that it's worth it to
switch over to html reports from word or
pdf
it'll depend on the age of the person on
the committee so i found it
every committee has one person that's as
old as i am
and and they want to see paper not just
pdf they actually want to print the darn
thing
and that's that's kind of a lost cause
so i would stick to the younger
committee members giving them state of
the art
and then let letting them embarrass the
older committee member
i'm a big fan of html output so i
appreciate that answer frank
thank you guys all for attending that's
the end of this session uh
give a round of applause to all of our
[Music]
speakers
you